your boy Nick Swisher filling in for
Rich Eisen on the Rich Eisen show ladies
and gentlemen we are blessed and honored
to have my boy Ben Lyons and receive his
story remember the first time you met my
wife was it at the wedding there's that
the way that Jamie and cutters when I
was like Mariah you're gonna meet this
guy Nick Swisher he's awesome he just
rips he crushes alright she's excited
she excited we get up there a little
late that's Friday night so she's
already gone up to the room but he comes
back down he's at the bar and he's
wearing a t-shirt that says don't bro me
unless you know and your wife by far you
married
what is this coverage that everyone
talks about you out kicking what is that
well check out my been on Twitter and
Instagram and I am been lying on Nick's
talk these days on our generic tweets
more assists than Kobe right more
revenge just for the Knicks in general
right I mean obviously with the Kevin
Durant injury that changes a lot of
things moving forward seven days before
an be a free agency starts I mean come
on hoops is right up your alley it's all
about how you look at life it's
perspective the most nicks thing ever
would be to sign Kevin Durant and then
the ruptured Achilles look your heart
goes out as it professionally I'm sure
as fans your heart goes out to Kevin
Durant you want what's best for him I
want him in New York so badly I'll take
the redshirt year of course I want him
to come to play for the Knicks just talk
to him going to Brooklyn today that's
the rumor that's out this morning I hope
not I would hate rich climbing for the
rest of my life I've known him since we
were like in high school I'd like to
feel so now at the collegiate
arch-rivals if rich sends Katie the
Brooklyn
that's yeah there's a betting favor now
they are the betting favorite yeah - 125
RG Belle or someone Vegas say that uh
yeah they said kairi's going there -
that's been the long rumor Kyrie and
Durant in Brooklyn with the red shirt
year um yeah I mean look Barclays is a
nightclub with the lights turn on that
place is the worst
and what I don't like about the Nets
move to Brooklyn is they pretend that
all the years in New Jersey never
existed can we get right can we get us
Stephon Marbury Appreciation Night can
we get like some acknowledgement of the
fact that they played basketball before
they move to Brooklyn but yeah I mean
Kerry I said Kerry Kittles Vince Carter
Jason Williams I mean you know those
scenes were awesome it was the finals
Jay kid Derrick Coleman may you still
love going out because you're so cheap
to go out there Nick the Knicks were so
good in the not anymore anymore so what
else is new ma'am everything's good man
I'm excited dude because in addition a
lot of this hosting stuff through a lot
of producing stuff you were really
supportive of film we released this year
in search of greatness by Gabe Polsky
let me break it down real fast if you
haven't seen this documentary you need
to write we've got three main guys in on
it we've got Pele we've got Jerry Rice
and we've got Wayne Gretzky arguably
three of the greatest that they've met
that have played those three and said
what's the idea of unlocking human
potential right and why did Wayne
Gretzky Jerry Rice and Pele become these
icons in their sport when they're by no
means the biggest fastest strongest
course but it's because they just had a
love of the game and they were able to
have that love grow when they were
children growing up and they weren't
over coached and over a a you'd and over
specialized they played other sports
they trained other muscle groups they
had other interests besides the sports
so that was a film we put out at the end
of 2018
now on iTunes and stuff but the idea of
bringing the culture conversation sports
together athletes as artists that's sort
of what I'm about and and and I trying
to do as a storyteller so we have a few
projects coming up being released in
2019 and through the rest of the year
and I just love where you can bring
sports and culture together I did it
with my Rock the Vote camp just getting
there Golden State Warriors in the WNBA
behind voting and getting there were
another voice out there so anytime you
can you know yes X's and O's of the game
we can yell at you know players and the
other team and HECO and you know I like
to sit in the bleachers and when you're
in Yankee Stadium you're my friend but
I'm throwing quarter that's wrong
battery you know that's part of the gate
but there's a larger game of life and
whether it's through film or some of
these other projects that we're working
on I like to try to play in that sandbox
yeah once again your boy Nick Swisher
sitting in here for Rich Eisen on the
Rich Eisen show talking to my main man
the one and only Ben Lyons talking a
little bit about the dock that they just
released a little bit ago in search of
greatness and one of the things I took
from that dock the thing I really really
appreciated the most was from Jerry Rice
and it and it may be like the most
simple saying but you don't have to be
the best athlete on the field to be the
best athlete on the field right I think
you took passion right pehle talking
about not boxing kids in and I think for
myself being a coach moving forward
right I think that's what we do a lot we
like physically show people how to do
things and I don't think that's how it
should be done nowadays what do you say
to a young baseball player out there
says coach swish show me a batting
stance show me some of the all-time
great hitters right you show them call
your strips he's gonna bring it - it's
all about feelings all about that kind
of again like I said at the top people
doing exactly what they should be when
you see it and it's natural when you see
our Jay Baer and he's wearing the pink
suit he's got a diamond to look like new
money you know but the the idea of kids
finding their way as a parent I can
imagine especially when it comes to this
youth sports stuff has got to be
completely overwhelming or intimidating
even as a former athlete yourself but to
give kids the the freedom to fail the
that you don't have to be in the
backyard doing crossover drills like go
play go go play soccer go work on other
thing goes Yoga like go have fun go be a
kid just got yourself yeah and then
you'll find your way as you get older
and if you have that great gift of of
greatness that exists within those guys
then hopefully that'll be able to come
out well obviously it'll shine out
through I think we try and force that
issue very early in line if you don't
make the traveling team at 6:00 you're
not gonna make it at 7:00 and by anyway
let's talk more NBA right the NBA Draft
just happened Xion Williamson huge name
coming out right now obviously your big
rj barrett guy moving forward with the
knicks
what do you think of this draft class
man i'm telling you we got some high
flyers we got some big names jay Morant
right there second pick in the draft you
know it's it's interesting we went
through a phase where it was a lot of
guys named gesundheit guys we heard guys
from overseas guys from around the world
and yeah there are a few international
players but there's a lot of big-time
college programs Michigan fourth year in
a row with a first-round draft pick
didn't see any Buckeyes on the board so
you know that you see guys DeAndre
hunter from Virginia you see Zion from
Duke you saw camera dish from Duke yeah
that might be one and done what guys
from big-time college programs are
getting picked and it's the accumulation
of stuff right no the reason that Lakers
were able to get Anthony Davis they had
a lot of stuff yep and sometimes teams
they run out of stuff when they start
paying guys you saw the Warriors they
ran out of stuff when all their guys got
injured so the Hawks the Cavs the the
teams at the bottom of the barrel
they're accumulating dudes they're
accumulating assets yeah someone's like
in football where the formulas you got
to win now with a quarterback who's not
getting paid you got to win now and you
have star players who aren't getting
paid don't know the Mitchells on a sweet
Dee sweet or the Utah Jazz and they can
be a playoff team every year you see
like Aaron judge he's on a cheap night
you know even even New Orleans they're
gonna have to decide you do you paper
editing room do you give him an
extension when he comes up for like a
karl-anthony towns or a Devin Booker you
know in those situation so man it's
nerdy it gets it's gets fun when it's
like the 46 pick and the Knicks draft
that Lithuanian
a couple years ago I think seven out of
the 15 all-nba guys were the 15th pick
and higher the year that Isiah Thomas is
on be a DeAndre Jordan and Yanis so you
get value for guys deep in the draft so
you know pay attention that late at
night when you know you're seeing guys
you might not have heard of now but a
couple years from now it might be all in
Viet I'd like to get your take on this
and we and we were talking about earlier
Brock we were talking about happy was an
hour one how you don't necessarily need
to have three NBA superstars to win a
championship no you have grown ups right
you have mature grown up psyche I
remember I was I was homesick the other
day and I was watching NBA TV and
they're replaying a bunch of Finals
games and I'm watching like bison daily
verse like Antoine Carr you know it's
like 97 low-post then the final scores
in the eighties yeah it's like you can
have all these cool young players tre
Young's awesome all these guys are
fantastic remember we're playing in May
and June he was playing Danny Green Kyle
Lowry serge ibaka grown-ups you know and
so yeah that's where you see what these
teams now if you go all-in on these
three Formax guys and then you have a
bunch of shmedrick's
you're left like cockroaches and the
lights come on you gotta have an epic
game so fast now the shots are so
there's so many more shots that are
getting put up you got to be eight nine
ten deep now yeah and the Warriors just
weren't it was a war of attrition
Raptors won out yeah of course and the
way the three-pointers change the game I
mean ever since you know Steph showed up
I feel like in high school you were not
allowed to shoot outside the lane right
it was like ten-foot jumpers we're right
there and that's in you stay up in here
let's sharpshooters go out there but
we'd sure like a Charles Oakley without
the 18 footer Oh bro I was like a Johnny
Stockton like give me the ball and I'll
pass it right back dirty players
guys enjoy this style the evolution of
the NBA now yeah I do I do love the flow
of it it reminds me when you're playing
pickup with your friends and you're out
like a full court that's not
five-on-five but small enough for like
three on three or four for full court
for us civilians yeah I like it and it
brings the game back to skill and the
refs you swallow the whistle a little
bit in May and June it gets physical the
games weren't in the finals a hundred
and thirty and a hundred like the
regular season those Knicks 90s games
you look at the score I guess the rock
is 74 68 that's why it's so hard to
compare players from one generation to
the other
right it was a way different game back
with Jordan played like literally dudes
were like clotheslining him and now that
mean like big twos all day yeah but then
John was also not playing in a league
that had a hundred dudes from around the
world and some of them were seven foot
three and can shoot the three like it's
just a bonkers league right now so it's
not full-on Starship Troopers football
like next was a deep reference one
Casper Van Dien is a quarterback and
they run it up but it's getting there
it's getting video game like yeah for
sure right once again Nick Swisher's
sitting in for rich eyes on the Rich
Eisen show chatting a little NBA hoops
with my guy been lying this doesn't stop
dude it's summer man it's summertime and
it's LA she's drooling
what else is going down WNBA and you a
couple Sparks games this year kids
Parker just came back they got whacks
the other night by the missus 5:30 but
la is become you know I'm from New York
the Knicks are my thing but in New York
will always be the mecca and it's the
city's game because we don't have fields
and golf courses all over this but here
in LA it's the capitol basketball right
now and the guys are working out here in
the summertime all the free agents are
you have all these 15 16 year old kids
calling in to sport sports talk radio
being like I saw David phys Dale in
Beverly Hills he was with quasi trainers
girlfriends cuz
and Swisher was there so he's going to
the cab let me ask you about him real
quick we've all been seen the clips
online on Instagram or whatever if his
name was not lamella ball what kind of
prospect do you think he is I almost
feel like he is a child actor or gone
like off the rails in some way right
like he's just I mean his basketball
journey has been so all over the place
it's like you look like a Lindsay Lohan
she's just everywhere so like would she
be like the the the talent that the
actress if she weren't Lindsay I don't
know I mean lamella ball like a real
prospect I haven't felt that from anyone
I haven't heard him commit to a big-time
program we feel his currency in the
culture because of the last name and
because of the awkward shot and the
crazy shots and the Instagram moments
but I took my hat to him to go out there
to the Dru League this summer and expose
he's playing great it's playing great
he's getting beat on he's doing his
thing and and he's you know from
Lithuania from River Plate from Chino
Hills to Lithuania to Ohio and now he's
going to Australia now in Australia
which is great I was just in Australia
in November and they are basketball
crazy
he's 1718 right yeah so I don't think
he's a real prospect yet he's bo Boll
real prospect I mean he dropped to the
48th spot ten games in Oregon I mean so
I think some guys can sell you on the
height for a little period I'm rooting
for the melon Suzy wants to be the
number one pick in the draft I enjoy
watching I think Alonso is great I just
think he's gotten unlucky with some
injuries but I think he's a good player
but he didn't subscribe to that in
search of greatness theory that kid was
playing basketball his entire life why
you see the injuries at a young age
Lanza ball should not be brittle he
should not be over trained and have
these recurring ankle of things and knee
thing like you know he didn't someone
tells me that 14 years old he wasn't
playing baseball he wasn't just out
there being a kid he was in the backyard
training he's in the NBA so what do I
know but I think I think lamellas got a
real shot if he can figure out that jump
shot
Wow
comes with the ball just in general yeah
that movie right there okay so it's the
anniversary of Spaceballs release in
1987 one of the great films spoofs of
all time of course but surely today
what's the best it's a movie spoof best
movie spoof so of course you got
Spaceballs Austin Powers kind of does
the spy game stuff hotshots take on
flight action John boutté was a spoof
expert he loves the genres Naked Gun
there's the Fonz around a bunch there's
so many the scary movies all those types
what's your favorite what's there's a
lot of good ones the Wayans brothers
obviously dominating that that arena
my dad's quote is on the box I think of
naked gun or Naked Gun two and a half I
was in high school I was 18 my high
school baseball team went to a nice New
York City private school we did spring
training in Arizona we are staying at a
motel across the street from the Arizona
Mills Mall and we went to a test
screening of scary movie where they're
just testing it randomly and some
shopping malls so I'm 20 deep with my
high school baseball team to see scary
movie I I don't think I've ever laughed
so hard that movie blew us away it was
so funny they made three or four other
like that cos scream was a spoof movie
itself in some ways not full-on spoof
right but it was satirical of the genre
and made references to previous you know
kind of scary movie trope so this was
like super meta right and that it's like
a spoof of a satirical film so I'm going
scary movie as the spoof movie from
thanks from well before we let you go
man's been absolutely awesome speech
come to life personally that's just but
I gotta ask you about the partnership
with the PG a you have coming up and
yeah I'm really excited starting in
August I'm gonna be doing a series for
PGA Tour comm and for scratch where I'm
gonna be profiling different charity
golf tournaments around the
world and around the country we go to
jail and roses tournament Detroit where
he benefits the junior la he's
Leadership Academy we're going to
support Charles Woodsen's Foundation
open Napa I'm gonna play for chill with
Charles I'm going out to support Klay
Thompson's Foundation when I get off the
tee they say it's like Mike Trout yeah
man I love the game of golf from the
fact that these charity tournaments
exists out there we can bring fans who
don't get the access to those events and
shine a light on all these charities
like Jalen Rose run him running a school
in Detroit for a long time the
Leadership Academy I was on his in his
family on family feud to raise money for
and now we're gonna raise money for it
through the golf thing and anything that
we can do but on our platforms to raise
awareness raise money just show that
there's a world outside of ourselves I
think we got to do so I'm looking
forward to that this summer should be a
lot of fun with PGA Tour I mean this is
amazing as much as you give back and as
awesome as the platform you're on you're
using it to do unbelievable things
brother across the palm we'll hang out
man I can't wait to say this to Nick
Swisher on TV and radio see you in
London your boys for rich eyes on the
Rich Eisen show my boy Ben Lyons but
thanks man thank you so much for coming
on my friend I appreciate you baby for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app